25 oscar nominees went home with some  pretty nice swag  these swag bags worth a little more than  137  thousand dollars  gifts include ten thousand dollars worth  of plastic surgery  a life coach session worth twelve  hundred dollars get one who could use  that  twenty five thousand dollars in home  renovations a three night stay at a  scottish castle and a small plot of land  in scotland that comes the title lord or  lady that and much much more all you  have to do is be nominated for an oscar  wow it's as simple as that and you too  can get those swag bags but okay how can  well you can only be one lord or lady so  how can everybody i guess  and were they saying you get to stay at  scotty's castle  [Laughter]  absolutely